dusk is hunting time for the world's
deadliest insect the anopheles mosquito
is responsible for malaria a disease
that kills nearly 1 million people each
year but now a young chemist has come up
with an innovative way to fight both the
mosquito and the disease his ambitious
goal is to save 100,000 lives by 2020
apologies metabolism for decades people
in Africa have died of malaria the
disease is responsible for many problems
here I think it's important that we
Africans ourselves find a solution but
that's not so easy each year some two
billion dollars are invested in
anti-malaria programs but so far all
attempts to eradicate the pathogen have
failed many approaches are both
expensive and impractical says jahani on
Deko he wants to do it differently with
a simple but effective weapon we decided
to work with soap because it's a product
that can be easily integrated into
people's everyday lives soap is used in
ninety-five percent of all African
households including the poorest far so
soap is not only an effective cleansing
agent its smell also repels mosquitoes
the protective function is based on a
combination of essential oils obtained
from local plants at night Nets keep the
mosquitos at bay but during the day and
early evening there's little protection
my dear Nnamdi shanty I'm a construction
worker and I'm very exposed during
working hours I often get bitten so it's
hard not to get infected with malaria
repellent creams are expensive and
rarely effective data LeBlanc Dallas you
have to constantly reapply it and you
still get bitten far so soap will cost
no more than conventional soap and
promises protection during the critical
times of the day not obvious it's a
daddy that was our goal is to provide
six hours of protection this would have
the risk of infection that is
the competitor nepotism the idea of
creating an anti-malaria soap came to
the chemist while studying for his
master's degree in Wagga Ndugu misses on
tech university we did courses on
setting up a company like how to design
a product what benefits it will bring
etc it wasn't i open up since 2015 geha
has been supported by IT specialist
folclore van mainly I came here because
of I mean the vision of jahar about like
a new innovative way to tackle malaria
and whilst we know excited to to
children to join jail and and see how we
can work together to to fight malaria
from closure on takes care of the
financial side because research is
expensive I mean in Burkina Faso it's
pretty difficult to find to fight
funding for innovation you find money
for development projects so if you want
to dig you know a wholesaler to get to
find water or if you want to build
school you can find money if you want to
innovate to create something you know
like what we do it's more difficult in
early 2015 the project was at risk
because there were no funds then a
crowdfunding campaign brought in more
than 70 thousand euros I always tell
myself if I can save one life or two or
perhaps even 100,000 my greatest dream
will come true and the sooner it does
the better because every two minutes a
child still dies of malaria